robert 23 ans employée dans un
supermarché de chalon sur saône a
disparu depuis vendredi elle avait
quitté son travail à 21h regagné en
cyclomoteur le domicile de ses parents à
saint loup de varennes
mais que s'est il passé vendredi dernier
entre 21h15 et 21h30
sylvie at elle été suivie depuis son
lieu de travail distant d'une dizaine de
kilomètres puis kidnappé est elle
attendue à cet endroit désert la famille
ne comprend pas les raisons d'un tel
geste
c'est pas les habitudes arrivé une demi
heure en retard était assez ponctuelle
voilà donc ça crée un un souci n'a pas
mes parents qui ont appelé les hôpitaux
on voit plus un peu partout et puis sont
allés à sa recherche ne sont pas les
loin cela un kilomètre mais ils ont
retrouvé la mobylette sur sac à main et
puis une chaussure qui était resté
dès les premières heures de la
disparition de suivi d'importants moyens
sont déployés par les forces de l'ordre
les gendarmes explorent tous les
alentours de chalon sur saône à la
recherche de la jeune femme et les
médias s'emparent très vite de cette
affaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire la
couleur de ses cheveux châtains foncés
famille amis voisins élus locaux se
mobilisent un comité de soutien
rassemble des centaines de personnes
tout est mis en oeuvre pour retrouver si
vivante
l'appel à témoin est lancé me lance un
appel à toutes les personnes
susceptibles de la portée des
enseignements pour en faire avancer les
enquêtes
c'est toute une famille puis atteint
sylvie messi
le portrait de sylvie et placardées un
peu partout dans la région et même
au-delà
l'hypothèse de la fugue ne tient pas
cette piste est tout de suite écarté
tout le monde sait qu'un drame s'est
joué ce soir là alors que sylvie aubert
était une jeune fille sans histoire
elle était assez gentil très très
sociable gens très douce
il avait des amis où elle sortait assez
mais les classes et sérieuse quand même
à laver un ami identifiez quoi mais son
comportement un peu étrange avait
interpellé ses proches dans les heures
précédant sa disparition la mère disait
qu'elle était inquiète elle était
préoccupée quelque chose d'après
occupait donc et ce qui est vu quelque
chose
la veille après cinq mois de recherches
intenses le corps de sylvie est retrouvé
par des promeneurs ou encore de la donne
à 40 kilomètres du lieu où ses effets
personnels avaient été abandonnées
les soeurs de sylvie ont reconnu hier un
bracelet et une bague découvert sur le
cadavre
mais c'est surtout la formule dentaire
analysés par autopsie qui a permis
l'identification on retrouve sylvie
aubert les poignets liés par du fil de
fer elle et dévêtue et puis le corps est
effectivement très dégradé
l' enquête se poursuit après la
découverte du cadavre de sylvie les
semaines passent les proches de la
victime
imagine des scénarios je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a surveillé qui la
connaissait et bêtes surveiller
certainement avec un cast en jean et
puis un blouson était méconnaissable
elle a les cheveux courts
c'est ma fille quoi sur sa mobylette
donc allez savoir qu' il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de passagers qui pouvaient la
librement voilà l'enlever qu'on en 2007
un rebondissement ce produit
un suspect apparaît dans le dossier
ulrich muenstermann un tueur en série
allemand qui a sévi dans l'yonne vient
d'être identifié
munsterman criminels sexuels
récidivistes est passé par la bourgogne
mais est il allé en côte d'or ou en
saône et loire l'homme roulait beaucoup
mais il serait possible de le suivre à
la trace
une trace que les avocats de la famille
aubert tente de remonter tout doit être
recouper et vérifier mais il se trouve
que son mode opératoire est assez proche
des traces qu'on va retrouver sur sur le
corps de sylvie aubert et donc du coup
on va faire des demandes effectivement
sur ce tueur je dirais que c'est encore
des vérifications qui sont en cours
martine aubert épaulé par les membres de
l'association christelle se bat pour
connaître la vérité sur le meurtre de sa
soeur
ces femmes ont connu le même sort les
assassins de leur fille n'ont jamais été
arrêtés
martin se sont moins seuls dans ce
combat ses parents ne se sont jamais
remis de ce drame
c'était
qui peut affreux quoi ils en sont morts
de chagrin trente ans après l'assassinât
de sa soeur martine continue à y croire
malgré les années des éléments matériels
ont été conservés au palais de justice
de chalon sur saône
il reste et selena mobile et par le son
palmarès mais les plaines poussière il
lui reste son sac il reste un pull lui
reste il ya des scellés
il y a aussi toujours de l'espoir qu'un
jour les langues se délient
forcément des personnes qui ont entendu
des choses dont elles n'ont pas témoigné
ça n'est jamais trop tard ça n'est pas
trop tard puisque ce dossier est encore
ouvert donc il peut encore être
travaillé pendant plusieurs années et
j'espère en même temps que certains
scellés pourront parler il qu'on pourra
peut-être avec certaines expertises
découvrir des traces exploitables
les récents rebondissements intervenus
dans d'autres affaires de l'association
redonne aujourd'hui du courage à martin
pour mener le combat du président mais
s'accroche m'accroche et en public
peut-être lui su comme les deux autres
dossiers et pop arrêté pour suivre un
boni